oh hi welcome to my kitchen I got a new
pair of pants I'm really excited about
it
the little galaxies anyway today is
national grilled cheese day so I am
going to not make you a grilled cheese
sandwich what I am gonna make you is
some peanut butter and jelly but I'm
gonna show you how to make one in a
blender anyway leave me some comments
below and what you'd like to see me make
next and let's get this started
I love my pants okay
it's time to make these peanut butter
jelly sandwiches I've got two loaves of
bread jelly jelly peanut butter
marshmallows chocolate chips more jelly
cool I also got some bananas but these
are for me not for you last but not
least I got some bamboo skewers so that
my sandwich won't fall over you'll see
what first things first I wash my hands
let's get a plate out this is let's see
the first thing that I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna blend up some bread and some jelly
and peanut butter inside of my sandwich
is going to be another sandwich
mind-blown
let's open up our bread roll up the
sleeves in there you are very jelly
we're gonna put our jelly into the
blender obviously because we didn't need
to make a really nice mix to put inside
of our sandwich I think a whole whole
jar of jelly is enough okay alright now
that we have our jelly in the container
I don't really know what else to do next
Red Solo Cup I'm gonna fill you up
jelly water check
now what we want to do put a little bit
pink butter in here this right here is
four pounds of peanut butter a servings
per container 57 oh yeah let's just do
one little scoop see how it get off of
my spell no let's do it real big scoop
this is a very heavy thing peanut butter
I'll just um put some more in see what
happens
maybe a little bit more shy I don't know
oh my water in right lid goes on it's
looking real thick
that's good that's what we want you guys
don't know is we need to put some bread
inside of the blender guy get real nice
and good because I want to have the
consistency be that of peanut butter and
jelly little are you gonna know that
there's actually bread inside of your
bread okay there we go
hmm all right
wonder what this tastes like bet it
tastes great let's just mix you up real
good I'm just gonna help you out blender
this smells delicious smells like peanut
butter and jelly
problem is we gotta get oh my god this
is absolutely just it looks like vomit
it looks like friggin just puke we need
more bread
we need more bread now that we have our
our mix it's time to make the sandwiches
so what I think I'm going to do is put a
big ol there this bread and just pour
this delicious liquid into it just
sticky right there don't really know
what I'm doing
oh wow that looks great really just
hollowed out I think I need a bigger
knife this is what we need this is what
we needed the whole time great this is
just a beautiful masterpiece so the
problem is these are probably going to
fall apart
where's mystics so this is what we have
so far okay I think I might have to make
this go all the way to the top yeah
didn't do a very good job of making us
even but what I do want to do is I want
to seal it so that nothing will come out
I'm just gonna eat your hands and just
dab it on the sides okay that's not
working at all that's this is not even
working no okay bad idea what a stupid
idea why would I do this why would I do
this obviously that didn't work out so
well so let's see what happens away pour
the mix in do the shoe oops
start it at the bottom now we're here
yeah what I do
what do I do
who thought this was a good idea so we
gotta do push it down a little more I
don't know we have a leak we have a leak
we have a leak no
oh gosh no dry erase away camera this is
what happens when you don't have a curl
do now I made a big mess and everything
is I hope let's just take this garbage
disposal works Oh
okay guys well thanks for watching um
let me know what you'd like to see me
fail at making next beginning I just
click lights the thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe and I'll see you in
my next video
you